yankees best pitcher is going to tow the
slab in the booking down bronx and
the scout report yeah he's human we
showed his last timeout down in texas
a couple of homers couple of walks
meredith mentioned in his career
home numbers in the bronx and 11 career
starts well under two and
well that's what you want from your
leader of your pitching staff
here is cole's 3-1 and it's grounded
weekly to
short taurus feels and throws one away
just a solid
guy to have in the lineup every day fly
ball to gardner
two outs oh
nice grounded to odor from short right
field
fires and just gets dylan sees throwing
the ball very well era below two and a
half out for his ninth start
he's undefeated this year 50 strikeouts
and 41 innings
three swings and misses two sliders and
a fastball and it's been
a pleasure luke voight who was in the
ninth spot
yesterday and here he goes after a fast
ball and slices it to left where andrew
vaughan times to put it away
really hard to believe that until this
run
in left field he was a first baseman a
lifetime infield back and straight away
the pitch
line shot to right he hit it right at
adam eaton
here's the 0-1 mercedes swings and
grounds one to third
picked out by geo go to second one on
the first double play
the ball was hit to geo and gito quickly
approached it
and made a short hop pick up and that's
how he started the double play
he's got some gloves here's the payoff
struck him out swinging to end the
inning
one two that's called strike three
here's the o2 again swing and a miss he
struck him out
at 97 on average there's the slider and
there's the takedown of on duhar
uh one hot bird to first go to second
and they got the double play ford got it
stepped down the back that took the
force off
he threw to taurus who put the tag on
vaughan and the one-two pitch
strike three eaton down looking
hopefully
not to be repeated
mike ford wanted to do something mean to
his baseball bat
as andrew vaughn is in to make the catch
some interesting little connections here
in this game
fly ball pretty well hit the center but
it's going to be
caught by garcia two outs
voigt hits the ground ball to the left
side it's gloved by
monkata and he'll throw to first and
that's it for the yankees
everything everything leads to the line
okay
agree down on strikes
could this be another double play tough
hop there's one on to first it's another
double play
on the ground tim roaming for round
number one
lined into right field that is going to
be a base hit in front of eaton
and that is the first hit for the
yankees today
labor torres with an opposite field home
run in the seventh last night to give
the yankees the lead
that one is ripped into left center
field it's a base hit
it's gonna split the outfielders and
roll to the wall judd scores
here comes your shella they're waving
him home he'll score
it's a two-run double for glaiber torres
and the yankees lead
to nothing there's root net outdoor odor
struck out in the second
swung on and line to left center field
on the run
and can't get the ball is garcia it
rolls all the way to the monument park
wall
racing around third is glabor he scores
it's a ribby double a ribby for roogie
and the yankees now take a three-nothing
lead
since 2019 grandall with a ground ball
to the right side one down in the fifth
three-nothing yanks
nubbed in front of the plate higashioka
gets an angle
two away swinging and a miss
powered it right by him at 99 miles an
hour
pitch swung on and hit in the air to
left
gorham went back he's racing in racing
and it drops
devon when he swung by the way i thought
the same thing bonded
i thought the ball was gonna be in deep
left field
but he got it i guess off the end of the
bat
ground ball base it gardner with a
single moving to second
is voight so the bases are loaded for
glebe torres
line drive it's a base hit to lafiel
boyd scores
here comes gardner here's the throw it's
cut off it's a two-run
single for torres he has four ribbies on
the day
and the yankees have a five-nothing lead
chopped up the middle glebe torres is
there
and they turn two there's one
and there's two fourth double play
turned by the yankees mike ford will
lead up for the yanks as we hit the
bottom
of the sixth inning
pitch is hit in the air to deep right
center it is high
notice far good is gone oh
there's a ford in the yankees future a
long
home run of bombaroo to right center
mike is forward tough he homers to right
and the yankees take a six-nothing lead
garrett cole has thrown 75 pitches
swing and a miss 99.
swinging a miss overpowered him at 100
miles an hour
and the 02
strike three that'll do it as he strikes
three out in the seventh
and works out of a jam
give grondell points for hustle as an
duo rips one into right center field
that's a base hit it splits the
outfielders and it goes to the wall
torres rounds third they're waving him
home here's the throw it's cut off
he's in there it's an rbi double four
and duhar
and it's seven nothing yankees
two two madrigal hits it to left field
on duhar is back on it and he's not
going to make the play
madrigal plops it down on the warning
track and nick's on his way for three
he is there standing up
grounded to third they're gonna come
home
and they get the out
[Applause]
fly ball right field frazier is there
and the yankees win their fifth straight
game
and there's a lot to dance about if
you're a yankee fan
as the yankees win their seven straight
series